-It is so good to see you, pal.
-It's good to see you, too.
-Thank you for being here.
Congratulations.
You have a new baby.
-Yes.
-A beautiful, beautiful baby.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-Wait till you see this baby.
-Oh, yeah.
This is the newest picture.
This is yesterday.
-Oh, my goodness.
Look at this.
She's cute.
[ Audience "Awws" ]
-Isn't that
the most perfect baby
you ever seen in your life?
-She's really sweet.
And I had a boy first,
and she's a girl.
And it turns out,
they're a little bit easier.
-Yeah, girls a little bit
easier than boys, yeah.
I have to tell you, you know,
I've known you a long time.
I love you.
And I watched "Yellowjackets,"
and it's --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yay!
Yes.
-100% fresh on Rotten Tomatoes,
by the way.
It is unbelievable.
It is so --
It's so scary.
It's too scary for me.
-It's fun.
My sister says
that when she watches it,
she's just filled with
such a sense of dread.
-It's not even dread.
I don't know.
It's not dread.
It's like the thing,
the mask with the fur,
a little eye coming out.
-Yeah.
-That scares me.
-That is scary.
There is some scary stuff.
Yeah. The eyeless man
is terrifying.
-Of course it is.
-Terrifying.
It's -- It's like things that
you go like, "Oh, this is --"
It's on a different level.
-Yeah.
-But I will say, also, you're
very funny in it, as well.
-Oh, thanks.
-'Cause I know you're funny.
You have a great sense of humor.
You're a jokester.
But I mean, I've seen --
-I'm not really funny.
I've never really been funny
intentionally for work.
-That's true.
But off-camera you're funny.
-Yeah, I'm a goof.
-But you're funny in this thing
when you're throwing the food
and stuff.
Yeah. No, I had a really good
time doing all that stuff.
-Season two, already announced.
Congratulations.
-Yeah. Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thanks.
We shoot end of August.
-End of August.
Is it fun?
Do you enjoy it, or are you
scared as much as I'm scared?
-No, I'm not scared at all.
And, also, my character's
a villain, so, you know,
I don't have to be afraid
of anything.
-Whoa.
-Yeah.
I always kind of --
Yeah, I always wanted to play
a character like this,
so it's really fun.
-Do you follow any of
the fans' theories online?
-I did.
Well, I'm old, so I didn't know
where to find these fan theories
for quite some time,
and then one of the younger
people helped me,
so I found them.
-Yes.
-And I think they're
fascinating.
It's really interesting.
-I thought it would kind of fun
maybe if I read some of the fan
theories from the Internet,
and you tell me
what you think of these,
and if they're true or not.
-Is the baby one on there?
'Cause that's the worst.
-What's the baby one?
-That was the one
I was obsessed with
and just thought was so insane.
"Do they eat Shauna's baby?"
-What?
-Right. And I was like,
"Why would we eat the baby?"
And then I thought,
"Well, we are really ashamed --
Everybody else is, like,
really haunted by what they did,
so maybe we do eat the baby."
So I had to ask the writers,
I said,
"We don't eat Shauna's baby,
do we?"
And she said, "No."
-All right, good.
Thank you.
No, do not.
That's good to hear.
We don't want anyone eating...
[ Applause ]
All right. You ready?
-Yeah.
-Your character, Missy,
is a present-day serial killer.
-Well, I mean, she does --
It's very --
I mean, she casually
murders somebody,
and she has a bunker ready
for kidnap victims.
I mean, that bunker
was ready to go, pretty much.
-Yeah.
So, yeah. So this --
-I would say that
she's probably done it before.
But I don't know.
Like, all of this is just
my opinion because
they don't tell me anything.
-Okay. So you --
She's done it before -- maybe.
-I think so.
It was really easy.
Casual.
[ Laughter ]
-"Jackie is still alive."
-I don't see how that one is
possible, to tell you the truth.
-Okay.
-I don't see how -- no.
I mean, she froze to death.
We saw it.
-I know we did.
[ Laughter ]
-I just don't --
-Okay, good.
Not possible.
-I don't think so.
[ Laughter ]
-"Misty caused the plane
to crash."
-I mean, we saw her
in that episode,
and she looked very surprised.
-Mm-hmm.
-Right?
-Well, as one --
-She looked shocked.
-Well, you don't want to look
calm as the plane is crashing.
-That's true. That's true.
Could've been a performance.
-She's not an actor.
-But she seems pretty --
I mean, she seemed
genuinely shocked.
Because she's not an actor.
She's on a plane
that's going down
with the soccer team.
-So she did a bad job
or a good job?
-It was the human reaction
to cover up, but she knew,
maybe that it was
gonna go down?
-Yeah, I don't know.
-The whole thing is insane.
-Yeah, it's pretty crazy.
-Okay. All right.
So you're saying no.
-I don't think so.
-"Misty has been working under
Lottie and her henchmen
and henchwomen this whole time."
-Yeah, that's interesting.
I think that is possible,
but I don't know.
-It's unbelievable.
-I know. There's a lot --
They don't tell us anything.
-Okay. But...
Some things you have more
confidence than others.
-Yes, that's true.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, some things
seem more possible.
-Juliette Lewis' character, Nat,
gets kidnapped
at the end of season one.
We all know that.
Does Misty have anything to do
with the kidnapping?
-Okay.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah!
-I heard a strong yes
from over there.
-Yeah!
-So when I first
heard this theory,
my initial instinct is no.
She would never do anything
to hurt Natalie.
But then,
the more I thought about it,
I was like, "Oh, maybe."
Maybe she did, like, Lenny
and the kitten, you know?
-Yeah, "Of Mice and Men."
-She wants it so much,
she's gonna, yeah, crush her.
Yeah, it's possible.
-Are you --
Did you know the show
was gonna be a hit
when you were doing it?
-No. No.
I mean, I liked it.
And I thought the concept
was good,
and the scripts became
increasingly, like,
Stephen King-y in tone,
which I was so excited about
because I love Stephen King.
-Fascinating and scary.
-Yeah.
-And "What is gonna happen?"
But I love the flashbacks.
I love the music, by the way,
is great, too.
-Yeah.
-'Cause you flashback,
you're like, "I was there,
and I listened to that music."
-I know, I know.
Liz Phair.
When they sing the Liz Phair
song, I was like --
-Dude, I put it on a playlist
because I'm like,
"Oh, yeah, I love Liz Phair."
All right.
Well, congratulations on that.
Thank you for clearing that up,
or not clearing it up.
I love it.
-Not clearing anything up
for anyone.
-I want to talk about
"Monstrous," in theaters, and on
demand, by the way, May 13th.
Another one
with lots of twist and turns.
-Yeah, it is
a psychological thriller
shot in the sort of tone --
or, the style of, like,
a '50s horror film.
-Yeah.
-And it's about --
Ostensibly, it is about a woman
and her son
in the late 1950s or '60s
who is escaping
an abusive relationship.
And they're moving
to a new town, new house.
And then when they get
to the house,
all these sort of
supernatural-feeling things
start to happen.
And the character that I play
devolves over time.
But as she devolves,
you realize that things
are not quite as they seemed.
-No.
And the final twist is...
-It's emotional, also.
Like for a horror film,
it's very emotional.
-Yeah, it is.
I agree, yeah.
-And as a parent, it's scary.
-Kind of beautiful and wild.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Christina Ricci
in "Monstrous."
Take a look at this.
-[ Breathing heavily ]
Cody, are you okay?
♪♪
[ Gasps ]
-Come on.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Christina Ricci.
I did want to mention, too,
as well.
Here's baby Christina Ricci
in "Addams Family" in 1991.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-With my favorite toy.
-Come on.
And did you fall in love with
movies when you did this?
-I did.
I think "The Addams Family" --
One, those movies were
so formative for my career,
because the first thing I did
that was really successful
was all about me
being allowed to do something
that was not conventional,
so it really sort of
shaped everything for me
in so many ways.
And then, also, I remember --
You know, I kind of fell into
being a kid actor.
I hadn't --
I didn't --
It was brought to me,
and then I was like,
"Okay, sure. I'll do this."
But I had always planned on
doing something different.
And then, I remember, I was 13,
and I was walking
on the Paramount lot and
shooting "Addams Family 2."
And they were shooting
"Coneheads" next door,
and then "Frasier"
was over here.
And I was like,
"Yeah, you know what?
I think I, um --
I think I want to do this
for the rest of my life."
-Really?
-Yeah.
-You figured it out
right then and there?
-Yeah, it was just such
an incredible experience.
-And now you're filming
"Wednesday."
-Yeah.
-Which is for what?
What is it gonna air on?
-It's on Netflix.
-Netflix.
-Netflix and it is --
-Tim Burton.
-Yeah, it's Tim Burton.
And it's a new --
It's young Wednesday,
teenage Wednesday in school.
-Yeah.
-Are you playing --
-Jenna Ortega plays Wednesday.
The only thing I can tell you
about my character
is that I do not play Wednesday.
-Okay.
That's the only thing.
-It's the only thing
I'm allowed to say.
-And how is she?
-Amazing.
She's so good.
So good and so wonderful
to work with,
and her Wednesday
is, like, really an incredible
great, modern take.
-I think you'd be a great person
to work opposite,
being a child actor yourself.
-Well, I always loved working
with adults who have been
child actors 'cause there's,
like, just an unspoken
kind of thing we all know.
-Yeah.
-It's really weird,
but it does work out that way.
-You're awesome, bud.
Christina Ricci, everybody.
"Monstrous" is in theaters
and on demand May 13th.